alors maintenant je vous faire tant pis
pour vous une interview nul on ne bouge
pas dans le junior
j'ai peur comme celui baptiste vous d
une bassiste convaincu convaincu d'un
beau parent jean baptiste aussi s'était
facilement marie bat marié ah oui c'est
une tradition familiale analyste chez
vous et conviction d'accord je respecte
toutes les convictions soucelles la
georgie celle-là oui alors interview
nuls dont j'ai les questions très très
con je ferais prendre à bail a pas de
toit et moi je sais bien les poser alors
est ce que vous préférez pierre ou
ginette j'avais dit que c'était qu'on
s'est on parle des mêmes ouais parce
qu'il va beaucoup de bière c'est votre
pierre votre papa pierre et votre moment
ginette vont pas faire un choix entre
ses paras s'il faut quand tous les deux
c'est un formidable et 2 donc on va pas
choisir sincèrement vous arrivez pas là
non non entre hitler et staline vous
préférez qui
vous en foutez c'est pas mon parent la
part de tous les deux non ya pas de
troisième a choisi j'avais mal au dos et
tout mais c est pire encore bien alors
vous partez dans un vaisseau spatial
pendant trois ans je crains le pire
alors vers une île déserte avec qui
danser le vaisseau spatial mais qui vous
préféré partir
cantona tapis ou locaux ouais c'est un
problème
au moins je vais apprendre des choses ah
oui ça si je voulais apprendre des trucs
n'avait pas la négative on aime on
n'aime pas oui mais il laisse pas
indifférent et c'est moi j'ai beaucoup
appris il m'a dit beaucoup de vérité
est-ce que vous préféreriez mourir tout
de suite là maintenant pas vraiment et
aller au paradis ou vivre trente ans de
plus et aller en enfer prend les trente
ans pas grave après sûr de rien après
c'est pas d'accord dans le figaro
jalouse des heures câble est là bien
c'est idéaliste des airs de vous préféré
partir avec une fille très moche au mec
très beau voilà la pêche
ouais pêche au thon alors autant alors à
l'essai du rocher qui sont contre et
c'est vraiment convaincu
j'ai répondu comme maingain ne fait pas
bon avec la fiq fils très moche ouais de
taper des du tout non vraiment prêt
n'ont pas non vie vraiment sûre si le
désert partir d'un conte enfants
à chaque fois si vous partez sur une île
déserte doit être la même à mon avis je
suis alors allé chanter là y'avait savez
ce spatiale indienne sa vie et même en
est avec vous j'y vais pas merci les
filles qui envoient des emails habitants
mouais si samuel le bihan vu une fille
moche c'est si guillaume qu'elle avait
une fille mais je suis d'accord
vous feriez quoi vous pariez tymoschuk
très fort même où seul mois de mai très
positive
j'ai alors moche très moche que je suis
prêt mais un mec très moche se trouvait
très intelligent pour nouvelle a fait
très belle est forcément très con
c'est la terrible préféré adopter des
jumeaux cleptomane des jumelles
pyromanes j'avais averti cleptomane
alors les jumeaux cleptomane oui parce
que des gymnases pyromane dans la région
vous vivez en plus voilà c'est mieux que
les taux moi ça ramène des trucs à la
mise en jeu peuvent être regardés en
script sega en slip de tibéri ou en slip
de delanoë en fait pas forcément comme
bush par 8,6
ni des récents vainqueurs dans l'âme